stunning food doesn't have to be
complicated keeping it simple produces
amazing results and keeps costs down
here are three more great easy dishes
that don't cost the Earth but taste
absolutely incredible
starting with roasted mackerel with
garlic and paprika
[Music]
first make a spicy paste by crushing
garlic in a pestle and mortar along with
paprika
sea salt
and olive oil
spoon the paste onto fillets of mackerel
and great inexpensive oily fish that's
really healthy and leave to marinade
when ready to eat put the mackerel
fillets on a baking tray inside up
season and roast in a hot oven
next make a Tangy potato salad
for the dressing mix Dijon mustard white
wine vinegar
olive oil
and saffron
and whisk until blended
four new potatoes and salted water
drain and lightly Crush
[Music]
add sliced spring onion and Spoon in the
vinaigrettes
[Applause]
to serve top the potato salad with the
roasted mackerel and drizzle with more
vinaigrette
[Music]
a healthy meal that makes the most of
cheap but delicious fish stunning
roasted mackerel with garlic and paprika
foreign
budget dish
is pork and prawn balls in aromatic
broth
[Music]
for the pork and porn balls in a bowl
add pork mince
then add finely chopped prawns
[Music]
diced Ginger
and chopped chives
[Music]
isn't
foreign
to ping-pong sized balls
[Music]
for the broth heat fresh stock
and add star anise oyster sauce soy
sauce and sliced Ginger
gently simmer
[Music]
fry the pork and prawn balls in a pan
until golden
then transfer to the bubbling broth
add handfuls of spinach then serve top
with finely sliced spring onions a
gorgeous healthy dish that uses Great
Value ingredients with amazing results
pork and prawn balls in aromatic broth
ready to eat in under 20 minutes
an incredibly simple recipe that's
perfect for using up leftovers easy
arancini delicious golden rice balls
[Music]
first chop mozzarella into small cubes
then take handfuls of leftover risotto
add a Cuba mozzarella and fold into a
ball around the cheese
perfect with leftover mushroom risotto
but it's great with any risotto
for the coating prep three bowls one
with flour one with breadcrumbs and one
with beaten egg
dip each arancini first into the flour
then the egg wash and finally the
breadcrumbs
then in a pan heat the olive oil and Fry
the arancini into golden brown
[Music]
drain and serve simply with lemon
arancini a delicious tempting treat
that's great for leftovers and Cooks in
under 10 minutes
three quick and easy recipes that give
maximum flavor for minimum cost
fantastic dishes that preview don't have
to spend a fortune to eat amazing food
at home nice here are three more of my
super simple spice recipes to get you
going
[Music]
first up a very easy chili and spice
white bait
start with the spice coating
toast Szechuan peppercorns and coriander
seeds in a hot dried pan to release
their flavors
[Music]
add chili flakes and grind the pestle
and mortar to make a fiery fine powder
combined with plain flour season and mix
[Music]
add olive oil to a hot pan
coat white bait in the spicy flour mix
then fry
white bait on an oily fish they are
healthy delicious and cooking minutes
once golden they're done
fantastic with garlic mayonnaise or a
simple squeeze of lemon
[Music]
ready in under 10 minutes chili and
spice white bait and easy simple spicy
dish
[Music]
my next amazingly aromatic recipe is
roasted squash hummus
[Music]
foreign
a classic Moroccan spice blend in a dry
pan toast Cinnamon cloves coriander
fenugreek and fennel seeds
then add mustard seeds and cumin
when the seeds start to pop they're
ready
at paprika and grind into a fine powder
for the hummus peel and chopped
butternut squash
put on a baking tray and add garlic
simply bashed and chopped Ginger
drizzle with olive oil season and
sprinkle over the spice mix
then roast in a hot oven for half an
hour until soft
allowed to cool and place in a blender
tahini a Nutty paste made from sesame
seeds cooked chickpeas a dash of lemon
juice
and a drizzle of olive oil
flits into a luxuriously creamy and
textured
spices toasted for maximum flavor
amazing roasted squash hummus
my final deliciously spicy dishes
curry spice sweet corn soup
[Music]
first The Fragrant curry paste
roast coriander and cumin seeds until
aromatic
then grind adding crushed garlic chili
powder turmeric and finely chopped
Ginger
[Music]
together with olive oil to form a thick
paste
for the soup fry finely chopped onions
in olive oil
[Music]
add the curry paste and cook to release
the flavors
add cubed potatoes
chicken stock
and season
when the potato has softened stirring
creamed corn
then add whole sweet corn kernels with
some of the juices
and transfer to a blender and Blitz
until smooth
for texture add more whole sweet corn
[Music]
it's ready to serve
wonderfully satisfying curried spice
sweet corn soup that packs an amazingly
aromatic punch
three more stunning recipes that make
cooking with spice simple
here are three more recipes to satisfy
even the keenest carnivore like me that
will max out on veg and won't break the
bank
[Applause]
starting with spicy flank beans with
feta and avocado
[Music]
first in a pan heat olive oil add
chopped onion and Fry until soft
then finely sliced garlic
and chili
add cumin
cinnamon and black beans then combined
cooked together until deliciously soft
these small beans come dried or in tins
and are a great cheap ingredient to make
dishes more substantial to serve dollop
the black bean mixture on crunchy
tortillas
topped with Cube ripe avocado chopped
fresh coriander and crumbled salty feta
cheese
spicy black beans with feta and avocado
a dish that's filling Frugal and tastes
fantastic
[Music]
my next great veg recipe is
leaking Greer Rusty with fried eggs
[Music]
in a hot pan sweat shredded leeks along
with a knob of butter and seasoning
next great parvoiled potatoes and Greer
a hard swiss cheese with a great nutty
flavor then combine with the softened
leaves in a pan heat oil and a little
butter
spoon in the potato leek and cheese mix
cook gently until golden and crisp
underneath
then slide onto a plate
flip over and return to the pan to
finish cooking
[Music]
finally for the perfect topping fry two
eggs
and place them on top of the rusty
top with fresh tarragon
[Music]
leaking gray Air Rusty with fried eggs a
simple but substantial dish that makes
the most of hearty root veg
a dish that takes as much time to write
on a Blackboard as it does to cook
chickpea cumin and spinach koftas with
tahini dressing
[Music]
in a blender put tin chickpeas cumin
seeds
paprika
and turmeric
and Blitz to a paste
[Music]
next roll spinach in olive oil and chop
finely then add to the chickpea mixture
sprinkle in gram flour made from finely
ground chickpeas then shade golf ball
side chunks of the mixture using a spoon
and rest in the fridge when ready to
cook heat oil in a frying pan
shall I fry the koftas until golden
brown on all sides
then rest them on kitchen paper to
absorb any excess oil
for an easy dipping sauce mix yogurt
with a dollar about tahini
and a squeeze of lemon
then stir in freshly chopped coriander
a mouth-watering dish that's perfect for
sharing
chickpea cumin and spinach coffees with
tahini dressing
[Music]